Harriette's great to see you here
tonight at the premiere for Penny
dreadful your character in the show is
Victor Frankenstein of course based on
the character from classic literature
how do you keep that fresh for yourself
well I mean it's John Logan that's this
bread fresh life into the whole thing I
think you know it's a really rich story
it's a vivid world that he's created in
late you know late 1800s in Victorian
England
he's woven a sort of original storyline
through bringing in some characters that
you might know but it really didn't feel
like it was sort of a tale that was
necessarily about these famous figures
of history or literally you know
electricity coming into it it was it was
its own world and it was just it was
great to be able to sort of see those
characters but in a fresh way in fresh
sort of places perhaps in their life
your character is a very forthright man
isn't he has this very particular view
on science in the world and he's an
anatomist
okay and he's an anatomist and you do
see scenes with him dissecting things
how realistic is that onset because it's
certainly pretty scary on screen well
maybe I mean that's I think we're hoping
to achieve the same levels of reality
that I am I hope I'm feeling it as real
as you're feeling it um I want to try
and frame the the world of the this this
amazing author kind of punk genius
obsessed Victorian scientists with some
reality because otherwise it just seemed
mental to me
so I went and went to Cambridge and sort
of spent some time with these professors
there who specialized in like Victorian
ethics or Victorian medicine and learned
that the advances that they were up to
at those you know in Victorian times
were huge and just as felt just as kind
of on the fringes of science as we feel
now you know with the incredible
advances that we can do with with with
creating new limbs people it's an
example now and so to learn about what
they're up to there and the kind of
practices they're up to and to try and
filter that through that kind of
obsessed genius mind of dr. Frankenstein
you see that maybe it could be possible
that they could create another life and
so it was fascinating to look at the
kind of history of it and and and then
obviously with John's whole new story
line that goes through it so yeah it was
fascinating doing what kind of parallels
you seen between that world that you
depict in that late 1800s Victorian
England and the modern world that we
live in now I mean you know the penny
dreadful itself is a gossip rag it's a
thing about stories it's it's sort of
it's a way of passing time it's it's
social media or Victorian here and then
I love it
and something about working with the
cars they're all great I mean you hope
that you can work with great actors and
great directors and great writers and
great designers and you know we were
lucky on this one we had an amazing team
and you know John Logan set the ball
rolling and through the the producers
and everyone it's just a great team to
work with so it's a pleasure to go to
work every day now of course he
mentioned John Logan obviously written
so many films his first foray into TV
you know him recently behind Skyfall
also working with executive producer Sam
Mendes you've got Eva Green he was in
Casino Royale here with the jaws and he
was bond at one time so Harry
future would you like to step into a
role in the Bond movies if so who would
you like to be well be a villain I
reckon we'll see why is that or would
you like to take on the villainous role
I don't know we'll see it's never to
speak to Harry thank you very much
you